thank you alejandro yes we are here with
another victor of today's round aram
hakobian aram welcome to the studio tell
us how it feels after this important
victory for you
well
it feels great obviously
but mainly i didn't do much to be honest
in the game because
it was all prepped till i got the a7
pawn
so after that it was kind of easy it was
just a matter of technique so
it was kind of a smooth game let's look
at the position as you were mentioning
so all the way until you picked up that
a7 pawn
let's see
did you feel like he was aware of your
preparation no absolutely not i think he
was
he was kind of surprised that i knew
till
uh till q4
and uh and we see right now on the clock
if i'm not
missing that it's 15 minutes against 1
hour and 26 minutes yeah i think
actually at this point he has four yeah
10 minutes right 10 minutes yeah
i think instead of a4 i could also take
on a7
but i thought that a4 is kind of the
killer move
explain to us a little bit why
well because if i take on a7 he can go
to k8 yes and let's say i go back bishop
e3
um king d7
and it's not so easy i'm pulling up but
you know he controls the squares king e6
h5
and maybe
and whenever you go 8.3 maybe he can
break with b4 and try to create some
counter chances yeah indeed
so after a4 i think i'm not sure his
best chance was probably to castle
what if he tries to maintain his pawn
with a6
a6 was a was a move but
takes
takes rook a7
and uh he's kind of stuck i go just
through k1 rugby 7 and uh
it's it's pretty bad he just cannot move
any pieces yeah if he goes bishop d8
something i go bishop c5
yeah this looks hopeless it's just lost
really bad
yeah but
in the inclusion of a4 and b4 now taking
on a7 of course you have a pass pawn
that changes the dynamics of the
position making the conversion much much
easier
which you actually did well that was a
very smooth game and yesterday it felt
like you got an advantage as well with
the black pieces against alex landerman
it feels like you're in great shape how
do you feel about your ship well it's
you know two rounds and uh in both games
opening went pretty well for me
so we
there's still like several rounds to go
so we'll see hopefully i'm in good shape
yeah did you prepare a lot for this
tournament
yes
well and it's showing a very dangerous
player certainly starting over at
webster university about 20 minutes away
from here one of the leading players
over there and certainly a dangerous one
uh for us
aram congratulations we're looking
forward to see you in the next few days
thank you congratulations on your
victory he says he didn't do much